el presidente de kosovo hashim thaci
renuncio con efecto inmediato este
jueves tras enterarse de que el tribunal
de crímenes de guerra de kosovo había
confirmado su acusación por crímenes de
guerra de razón como prometí no
permitirá bajo ninguna circunstancia que
un presidente de la república de kosovo
comparezca ante el tribunal presentó ser
públicos por lo tanto con el fin de
proteger la integridad de la presidencia
de la república de kosovo la integridad
del estado de kosovo y la dignidad de
los ciudadanos de kosovo y respetando la
asociación con la comunidad
internacional renunció hoy al cargo de
presidente de la república de kosovo los
ojos una dimisión que llega como una
promesa el presidente de la
autoproclamada república había declarado
en junio cuando una fiscalía especial
para kosovo lo acusó de supuestos
crímenes de guerra y crímenes contra la
humanidad que dimitiría si se
confirmaban las acusaciones en ese
momento
thaci clamaba su inocencia
todos el sudor
queridos ciudadanos podría haber
cometido errores políticos en tiempos de
paz pero nunca crímenes de guerra
si tuviera que volver a los días oscuros
de milósevic haría lo mismo
respondiendo a las balas del enemigo con
balas de libertad y sin dañar a ningún
ciudadano serbio romaní o albanés las
acusaciones de crímenes de guerra contra
el ejército de liberación de kosovo
surgieron por primera vez en un informe
de 2011 de la agencia de derechos del
consejo de europa tanto thaci como al
presidente del partido democrático están
acusados de casi 100 asesinatos y otras
atrocidades contra centenares de
albaneses serbios y romaníes durante el
conflicto contra serbia entre 1998 y
1999 donde murieron más de 13.000
personas